an é o quadro de pessoal aqui quem fala
é o dark seja muito bem vindo a ser mais
entendem é que o estrago de líquidos
tê-la em off da irmã que é basicamente
um jogo fácil né faixa que ocorre eu
gostava de ver uma batalha entre o sonic
o fórum série earth plan ué velocidade
pelo meio coloca-nos conseguir a pé não
piadas sobre morte não em ok estamos num
museu de arqueologia arqueológico vamos
fingir que estou impressionado nem sei o
que é que isto é nós temos de saltar 10
de arqueologia podemos inventar ou
comporta ou entrará em gestão esgoto não
sei se é pelo esgoto nas suas estruturas
nem já usavam esgoto clube tem uma
motosserra a não perder é uma moda
ninguém anda de motosserra né
ok não é um tratamento para o transtorno
que não é isso que caiu ao chutar eu
comece a aprender e aplicar outro
polícia ainda essa fadel então para que
é que eu tenho que fazer já pré isso vou
ter um polícia à mas fiquei vivo ainda
lá eu vou fazer outra vez porque apoia
não é então eu acho que a bola entrar
naquela porta do estado escolher uma
sorte pode ser útil
ai meu deus não não morrer agora aceitar
os que pensaram que o médio terá que
manter um carro bom o basquete era o que
eu acho que tu não saia um cesto lá isso
obrigado dark não também não foi sempre
usar o carro agora eu estou na estrada
da obstetra influenciam as mãos em
teatros do estrela então escolhi tempo a
carta inspirou ramo a pedra em pedra ela
não conhece a helicóptero já tá
complicada já que amava a música parar
aí
não não consistente chegou o helicóptero
com o senai para mais quente da terra
vão experimentar provável mais tupi de
que funciona por um turismo no ar
eu não vou fazer espera a atm escolher
né posso escolher o diamante o cabeça de
wellington silva escolherá cabeça de
ouro e diamantes né
aí eu sou fã do tiro procure manter como
aprovação e eu fosse entretanto não
estão na água e esgoto vivo
estamos na porta do estádio o que não
não seguir o mais lógico é que a
terceira picareta mas eu tenho quase a
certeza absoluta
nós vamos conseguir passar isso
conquistou capa o que eu escrevi um
avião uma bomba uma pistola ou caiu eu
vou escrever o chão
eu fui para o tucano os que passarem da
primeira como é que é possível nós temos
de ir pra grande que deixa o poder fugir
para uma casa que o cap gemini retrô mim
coisas retro e talvez vá pras coisas
retrô possível alguém não posso jogo não
deixa o ocorrer por simular o toque
temos várias coisas e agora está o que o
metroid temos um pé de cabra temos uma
pouca bola pokémon sabe e temos um super
mais rumo que é do que o super mário que
escolhe uma pode ser porque bola mais
estúpida fazer mais para lá entrei no
game boy que fizeram isso com ninguém
está com um ritmo médio prazo vai
agüentar
ok por mim eu vou escolher agora um
macho rumo a uma caipirinha de mas foi
como ganhar o hotel facto eu sou piratas
ou já não sair tanto em algum lugar do
centro do caso conta a irmã rocks um
canalha temos aqui uma x toque um
símbolo de iluminar queremos botar um
raio x não está o botão de
radioatividade quando vocês me honrado e
ouvir música é clinton caiu e tentar a
ventoinha não há ativos um lar
ae até no sector está alto mas por cima
de um robô com você elétrica
promovemos mas vocês clássico de amanhã
ela vai te consegues marcamos dois
filhos pelos teus eu vou achar a mulher
não conseguiu fugir
o diamante falar manel que passar isto
da maneira épica enef e isso já consegui
passar steel de duas maneiras eu acho
que ainda falta mais de outro mesmo
assim vou experimentar as coisas que não
experimentar só para ver o que acontece
tal eu vou escolher as botas do bueiro
solta aí não sei lá só tem encontrado em
quatro da esquina água e acho que
poderei aprender uma pistola de raios
laser e deixem o que está fazendo
espera-se uma minhoca terra
eu o rio por causa de uma minhoca
liquidificador não se precisa disso não
está o único ele fiquei lá é mesmo túnel
éo feito o elenco em pior do moleque
mirrado futuro
vocês vão ficar água e moléculas do do
ic2 vocês vão conseguir passar pelos
parentes
aparentemente chat vai e vamos tentar o
telecópio ter sob disputá lá pra cima
voz ao polícia em cima vamos usar o que
o piloto vem invisible nada disso fica
invisível não ver claro já na era o que
é que as pessoas o hábito se o nr
invisível não eu sou invisível ainda
sucede agora vai jogar quem eu vou usar
a moeda então a série não ocorrer o ps3
com 1 101 km temos o top ten o ipad
porque continuo falando para eu voltar a
portugal e agora uma em cima e sim o
diamante cai-cai contigo claro vamos
usar o uai eu acho que isso resultou a
pouco estamos a tentar outra vez eu sair
agora posso escolher entre o em ser
cantora está aquela assinalado 100 certo
temos o milan abrir janelas para entrar
e temos um hair é um puxa a marcação o
james bond mãozinhas tô era logo
apanhado de jaime vamos vamos criar uma
sacada do meu acho que o mais seguro
andar
isso supera eu vou eu fui insegurança
não exclui o martelo a sério
temos mais três opções temos um canhão
temos um x ou temos uma polêmica vou
conseguir como estava de madeira em
golfe de um trampolim quem não fala que
sorte que eu tive nada planeado esta
coisa temos um policial aqui em baixo a
partir do pescoço aí temos o dia
mantivemos uma ak-47 que não se quer
dizer que é só uma raiva ou mesmo de um
jantar que é saltar pois eu vou escolher
a raiva ou isso no fundo da mata mata eu
falei tudo tem que ser o diamante é isso
eu mantenho o político do irã
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar porque
com este magnífico filhos pra tenham
estado já sabem lá que favorito fiquem
bem até a próxima euro como eu tô com
vontade
e eu não sei porque acho que é ensinado